OK, so let's get into the hydroxy conversation.
You might have noticed that for the last week
or so, Donald Trump and Fox News have very
abruptly stopped talking about hydroxy chloroquine,
chloroquine, the medication that both Trump
and Fox and some others in right wing media
have been promoting for weeks.
As if it's a miracle cure for Corona virus.
And the reason they've stopped talking about
it mostly is that more and more papers are
being published almost daily that show that
not only does hydroxy chloroquine not appear
to be effective in treating coronavirus both
with and without a zero myson, the zie pack,
as Trump likes to say, it might actually be
causing more death.
Now, I want to be ultra crystal clear here.
If you watch this program, if you listen to
my podcast, if you
know me at all, you know I am willing to accept
anything that works for Corona virus.
I dont care if Trump was the first one to
mention it.
I dont care if a banka herself synthesizes
the treatment or cure.
Personally, I want to treat people with therapeutics,
a vaccine, whatever works.
As soon as humanly and safely possible.
I'm putting all politics aside because that's
the most important thing.
But from day one, Trump and Fox were going
crazy promoting chloroquine as if it were
a miracle cure before we really knew that
much about it.
Now I also want to remind you that it wasn't
wrong to hope chloroquine could work.
We talked about chloroquine before Trump ever
mentioned it.
I don't know if it was five days before 7
days, nine days, something like that.
I told you about chloroquine with us to throw
myson without
it.
What what we did, though, is I came to you
and I said, here's a bunch of stuff that is
being looked at.
We're looking at chloroquine with and without
as it throw myson, we're looking at Rum Desert
Vier made by Gilliard.
We're looking at for VVIP of there, which
is also called AB.
Again, that's a Japanese drug.
We're looking at a combination of two anti
HIV drugs.
There are studies being done about could the
tuberculosis vaccine or the polio vaccine
work not as a vaccine, but to trigger the.
Type of immune response that might prevent
someone or make it less likely that someone
gets infected with Koven 19 in the first place.
I mentioned to you dozens of things that were
being considered and that we should look at
scientifically, soberly, without becoming
emotionally attached to anyone in particular.
But for weeks, Trump and
HANNITY and Fox were going crazy about chloroquine.
Remember this?
Here's HANNITY talking about.
This is so irresponsible prophylactic use
of chloroquine with other things.
Mr. Vise, president, I'm holding up a letter
and I'm going to read from it in a second
from a doctor, then New York area.
And if I may read from it.
He has now worked with his his associates
and he has a regimen hydroxy chloroquine,
200 milligrams twice a day, five days, a zero
myosin, 500 milligrams once a day, five days,
zinc sulfate, 220 milligrams once a day for
five days.
This is what he has seen.
Him and his team of now treated approximately
350 patients and Kyra's chosen area of New
York.
Those hit particularly hard and another hundred
and fifty patients in other New York areas.
His results, we have had zero deaths, zero
hospitalizations, zero intubation.
Then, of course, Trump himself pushing this
wildly.
And I hope they use the hydroxy chloroquine
and they can also do it with zulfacar subject
to a doctor's approval and all of that, but
I hope they use it because I'll tell you what.
What do you have to lose?
In some cases, they're in bad shape.
What do you have to lose except possibly your
life?
And I could play dozens of examples of Trump
saying this stuff.
I won't do it today.
Imagine that you just sat through 20 examples
of that because they are out there.
Here's a doctor telling the blazes, Glenn
Beck, that the only reason people are questioning
the efficacy of chloroquine is because Trump
is pushing it.
Of course, that's not true.
Here's a drug that's been around literally
for ever.
Hydroxy chloroquine.
And it is being treated like a pariah.
It.
Do you believe that this is happening because
Donald Trump was behind it?
Absolut, I mentioned it.
That is the reason.
I absolutely think that's the reason I think
that that's why people are.
I have been attacked when I've treated patients
with this and we've seen improvement in the
patients.
Well, you might have noticed that neither
Trump nor Fox have been mentioning chloroquine
very much unless someone else brings it up.
And it's because many studies are finding
there's a really big risk to taking the drug.
There's a new V.A. study of three hundred
and sixty eight or 386 male veterans.
And it found that 28 percent of those Gallivan
given chloroquine died, whereas only 11 percent
of those who received the standard of care
without chloroquine died.
It's not definitive, but it doesn't look particularly
good.
It's not a perfect study.
There's another study from Brazil with similarly
concerning findings.
Other studies are also finding that there
seems to be no measurable positive effect
from chloroquine.
And there are people having serious heart
issues.
It's being tested both alone and with a zero
myson when Trump was promoting it.
You saw Fox News promoting it constantly.
Everyone
has gone almost completely silent with one
exception from this morning, which I will
get to in a little bit.
So during week 1 of April, Fox News mentioned
chloroquine.
One hundred and ninety four times in the second
week of April, Fox mentioned chloroquine.
One hundred and thirty eight times.
It declined a little bit.
In the third week of April, Fox mentioned
chloroquine 51 times.
And this week it is very, very few.
Now, you might say, you know, it looked promising
before.
So they mentioned it.
Now it's not looking as good.
So they're not talking about it as much.
So everything's fine.
That's not really the issue, though.
The issue is that they were touting it before,
even with Hanadi saying it could be taken
prophylactically when there was really no
more reason to push chloroquine than AV again
or Ramdas of year or whatever else
other, then Trump was promoting it like a
miracle cure.
Now they're not really correcting the record.
They're simply pretending it never happened.
The right thing to do.
The responsible thing to have done all along
would have been never touted as a miracle
cure from the beginning.
Report on it as one of many treatments that's
being explored.
And now you can continue to report on it and
say we have all these studies now that say
it's not working particularly well.
Report properly about this stuff without the
wild emotional propagandistic attachment.
Tomorrow's briefing, it wouldn't shock me
to see trumpet, let chloroquine listen.
I know I'm not a doctor, whatever it's called
hydroxy.
What was that?
That's a nasty question.
And you should be ashamed of yourselves.
Now they move on to the next round of disinformation
and it's mostly about text testing.
Moving on from chloroquine
altogether.
Now, there was one notable clip about chloroquine
this morning on Fox News.
And that's what I want to talk about next